remember bad baby
bad baby spelled with two h's bad baby
she is the girl who went on one of the
daytime trash shows and said cash me
outside how about that remember that
catch me outside how about that and uh
she became kind of a meme and and famous
for this so bad baby has just posted a
new look
she was a kind of
average looking white girl
uh with kind of colorful hair and now
she's posted after some kind of cosmetic
or maybe surgical makeover with lots of
tan product and things on she looks kind
of like a black woman
and she's dyed her hair jet black and
her skin has been darkened and she's
just presenting herself as a black woman
and so the reason I bring this up is not
because I I follow oh and she her hair
was yet black I'm sorry her new image is
that it's platinum blonde in a very sort
of dyed
out of a can way and then her skin is
extremely dark and she just she's got
big
you know obviously surgically modified
lips and she seems to have had some some
surgeries anyway she she looks much more
like a black woman than she previously
did I bring it up
because
it tells you everything you need to know
about white privilege
if White Privilege existed
black people would pretend to be white
because that would give them a privilege
but that's not what's actually happening
what's actually happening is that white
women are pretending to be black
Rachel dollazal pretends to be black
because it gives her social privilege
Jessica Krug you remember Jessica Krug
she was an NYU professor she's just a
regular old Jewish lady she pretended
for her career that she was not Jewish
but black Jennifer Lynn Benton
Jennifer Lynn Benton is a regular old
white lady from Indiana
and she pretended to be black and she
she had roles in BLM and all sorts of
left-wing activism
so you got Rachel dolezal's what Czech
German and Swedish
Jessica Krug Jewish Jennifer Lynn Benton
I don't know she's just some kind of
generic combination of of whiteness
all pretending to be black even Sachin
Little Feather do you remember that
Sachin Little Feather was allegedly the
Native American whom Marlon Brando sent
up to receive his Oscar for him and give
a protest of the awful treatment of
Native Americans just came out she's not
Native American at all
she's just a Mexican lady her name's
Marie Cruz she has no connection
whatsoever to the Apache Indians
because there is no privilege in our
present culture associated with
whiteness
actually there's only disadvantage it's
harder to get into college it's harder
to get a job it's the you're the only
race that you're that it is not only
permitted but encouraged uh to to insult
in our culture
we are told that white people are the
only race that you can't be racist
against so yeah of course I'm not
surprised at all that bad baby wants to
look like a black lady okay it just
shows you how different
the popular perception of reality can be
from the reality itself right now head
on over to kamikoto.com Knowles using
techniques that have been honed and
perfected by generations of bladesmiths
kamikoto knives are crafted only of high
quality Japanese steel each kamikoto
knife goes through a rigorous 19-step
process that takes several years from
start to finish with more than 100 years
of experience between them kamikoto's
expert bladesmiths shape raw Japanese
steel into hearty blades polishing and
sharpening them to an excruciatingly
fine single bevel Edge the sharp edge is
why comicoter knives can cut through
Meat and Fish like butter and why they
are used by Michelin rated chefs around
the world each knife is individually
inspected and comes with a lifetime
guarantee plus kamikoto knives come in a
beautiful heavy duty Ash wood box for
safe storage this stunning presentation
kamiko to a great gift during this
Christmas season kamikoto is now running
a Black Friday sale and offering my
viewers an additional fifty dollars off
any purchase with discount code Knolls
go to kamikoto.com Knowles and get your
knives set and help support this channel
another great example of this
Alex Jones
Alex Jones this is where I meant to get
to it at the end of last week Alex Jones
was just ordered to pay another half
billion dollars to the families of the
kids who were killed in Sandy Hook
Elementary School
so
Alex Jones had already been ordered to
pay almost a billion dollars then there
was another uh lawsuit that demanded
that he pay 2.75 trillion dollars that's
the GDP of many countries and then
he in fact it was the GDP of the United
States not all that long ago and now
they're they're ordering him to pay
another half billion it's going to be 10
gazillion dollars by the time that
they're through
not uh I'm not I'm not defending Alex
Jones okay Alex Jones he might be the
worst guy in the world I don't know Alex
Jones
but what he did the thing that they're
making him pay all that money for
essentially was get a story wrong on the
air
Alex Jones didn't kill anybody
Alex Jones he just said things on the
air that weren't true
the New York Times has gotten a lot of
stories wrong
New York Times got stories wrong that
helped lead to the Iraq War
New York Times has gotten stories wrong
that led to the Russia collusion hoax
plenty of people have gotten lots of
stories wrong
the way that the establishment media
reported on the George Floyd story led
to led to months and months of riots and
arson and looting and dozens of deaths
none of them are ever going to have to
pay one penny because they've got the
power and what we're told in this in in
our silly absurd culture is that people
like Alex Jones they've got all the
power and we go after him we're speaking
truth to power we're taking stuff away
from the man Alex Jones has no power at
all
he's just an eccentric guy who sometimes
takes his shirt off on air with a
microphone in Texas and they're going to
take that microphone away from him if
they can
if the perception of power in the United
States and the way that our political
system works is very different from the
reality
very very in America you basically can
never be held to account for libel or
defamation it's very very difficult
the libs will never be held to account
for any of that
Alex Jones will the the right wing
people certainly will today we will be
discovering all sorts of new genders on
tick tock
I usually interview people on on
Tuesdays but you know listen today today
is all about Trump's announcement we're
going to be talking later on for that so
I figured we needed to mix it up a
little bit get some open our minds on
these questions of gender the rest of
the show continues now you don't want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description
and join us
[Music]
[Music]